Annie is directed by Will Gluck and
stars Cove ensign a Wallis as the title
role Jamie Foxx Rose Byrne and Cameron
Diaz and this is the third feature film
adaptation of Annie and a completely
necessary remake totally necessary in
every way now you more than likely do
but just in case you don't know the
story of Annie it is about a young girl
who doesn't know where her parents are
she's a foster child her foster mother
played by Cameron Diaz is very very mean
they're singing and there's dancing and
this one has Jamie Foxx who's trying to
run for mayor and quickly realizes that
his popularity grows after he saves
Annie's life so we get to watch them
bond with each other and teach each
other about life and I get to sit there
and watch the whole damn thing that's
what I got to do in all honesty guys
this movie is a complete train wreck
disaster and I mean that every single
part of this movie embarrassed me it's
one of those movies that actually
embarrasses you and not just because
people just bust out singing you know
I've seen musicals that are good I've
seen plenty of good musicals but a
musical has one real job it's very
similar to any film tell a good story
but the one added thing that a musical
definitely should do is have good music
it should at least sound okay right I'm
not exaggerating when I say that every
time someone began to sing in this movie
I became embarrassed to be there because
the singing in this film is not even
good every single person in this movie
sounds as if they've been processed
through a computer as a singer one of
the easiest things you have to do is
lip-synch some of the lip-syncing of
this movie is even off there's a scene
where Cameron Diaz is like going nuts in
her apartment crawling around and
singing it sounds terrible but even her
lip-syncing is off
it's atrociously like unforgivable it's
the easiest thing you have to do just
memorize the way the song goes and then
move your mouth to the way it's supposed
to be if you watch the first 10 minutes
of this movie you know exactly where the
rest of the movie is going to go even if
you haven't seen any other previous
incarnation of Annie it's so predictable
everything is just set up for you it's
like page 1 here's this thing page 2
here's this thing page 3 here's this
thing there's the problem there's the
solution okay now wait two more hours to
see the rest of it happen and yeah this
movie is like two hours long
look I'm a big fan of Rose Byrne I think
she's a great actress and I've seen her
do really great work before I'm a huge
fan of Jamie Foxx I've liked him even
before Rae and collateral in 2004 I
think is very funny he's a good dancer
he's a good singer and he's a great
actor I'm embarrassed for these two
people to even be in this movie every
shot I see of them it feels as if they
are just crumbling somehow behind this
facade of their characters there's an
entire scene where they go to a movie
premiere and we actually see a fake
Hollywood movie being shown with all
these celebrity cameos and the jokes
they try to pull off to just they're not
funny let's talk a little bit about Co
Venzon a wallace now I am sure that she
is as sweet and caring and funny
charming little girl cuz she comes off
that way but I feel like her and the
entire cast in this movie has just been
thrown terrible direction and terrible
advice from anyone it just comes off as
the worst direction has been given to
everyone because everyone in the film
feels completely uneven and there's
these incredibly random montages like
where this crazy stuff happens like
Jamie Foxx and a bunch of kids are like
etta ice skating rink with candy and
he's just like pours candy on himself
and does all this really absurd stuff
that only works in a movie montage can
you just do this one weird thing right
there we'll get a shot of it we'll put
it in the montage okay yeah thanks for
doing that okay cool we put that one
part where you'd like stood and did a
wave like stuff that no one does in real
life you know it's just it looks funny
and appealing and cute in a montage look
I hated this movie okay it was terrible
I hated it I hated every second of this
movie it was embarrassing
it was embarrassingly bad sitting there
watching it I felt embarrassed like how
that's this bad I'm gonna give an E and
F don't see it don't see it at all
that's my recommendation - guys I got a
question for you what's your favorite
musical as always thank you so much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes